what's up my smooth skins it's time to
crack open a nuca cola and sink our
teeth into the very first teaser trailer
for Fallout the series a series that is
considered Canon if you haven't seen the
trailer yet I've left a link to it in
the description but come on back there
are some juicy details to get into also
if you like these kinds of breakdowns I
just finished one for the boy season 4
and House of the Dragon so be sure to
check those out here we are in Vault 33
which we can see by the number all the
way here in the back the rust and
flickering light suggest this is a place
that has seen better times the series is
supposedly set in the year
2296 that's 219 years after the Great
War a nuclear war between the United
States and China so if this Vault was
made before the Great War we're looking
at a place that's over 200 years old
2296 would also set this show 9 years
after the events of Fallout 4 and here
we get our first look at l pernell's
Lucy one of the main characters we
aren't exactly sure what compels her to
leave the Vault but her fellow Vault
dwellers do not want her going out now
if you look closely you'll see someone
either passed out or killed Lucy's made
sure there's this gap between her and
the others so no one follows her it also
appears that Lucy has a cut underlet
which may be the result of her leaving
the Vault I got to say I love the Vault
uniforms and some of you may have
noticed the PIP boys attached to their
wrists pip stands for personal
information processor and is a device
that helps our characters navigate the
Wasteland among other things the
exterior of Vault 33 is very much a
wasteland complete with skull and bones
although it's tough to see she may be
reaching for what looks like a gun
attached to her waist remember you got
to watch out for Raiders out here in the
Wasteland a gorgeous shot of the
completely destroyed Santa Monica Pier
season 1 looks to be set predominantly
in post-apocalyptic Los Angeles and
California with we'll hear voice over
from Michael Emerson's character Wiig I
still can't get over how good this guy
was playing Ben lus and lost he tells
Lucy that Vault dwellers are an
endangered species and that she should
go home because as we'll see life
outside the vault is dangerous Wiig
appears to be one of the first nonv
Vault characters Lucy meets on her
journey and it's possible this German
Shepherd is his the fact we see this dog
throughout the trailer but not wizig it
could mean he gets killed and Lucy takes
over as the dog's owner through these
ruins we can make out bodies that look
to be frozen in Ash like the bodies of
those found in Pompei now check out this
giant rad roach who is mutated almost to
the size of a window rad roaches are a
common enemy found in the games and
we'll even see the dog tearing one apart
one of the first locations Lucy stumbles
upon is this abandoned town that looks
aesthetically like good Springs the
starter town in Fallout New Vegas she'll
travel across these eerily beautiful
landscapes like this one where the ocean
has receded leaving nothing but desert
and the dilapitated remains of a ship
now the trailer shifts to focus on a
character named Maximus he's described
as a wanabe soldier who grew up with the
Brotherhood of Steel a sort of
paramilitary order that operates all
across the former United States its main
purpose is to preserve advanced
technology and regulate its usage so
we'll see a lot of advanced Tech in the
trailer including these heavily armored
soldiers using power armor we can see
the brother of steel logo emblazened on
this soldier's chest plate Maximus looks
to be stationed at this Brotherhood base
in these Salt Flats where several
helicopters known as Verte Birds
transport him and others we'll see a lot
of these soldiers and I absolutely love
the Sparks their boots make as they
scrape along the concrete check out this
jukebox here which initially looks like
it's outside in some sort of field Until
you realize this is actually the
interior of Vault 33 we get our first
look at Zach Cherry's character who is
pH phenomenal in Severance by the way as
the vault is under attack this could be
a Raider attack judging by these
characters here shirtless and an
overalls but it's also possible this
isn't a Raider attack at all but some
sort of vault tech experiment that turns
the Dwellers against each other the
purpose of the vaults were to increase
the chance of American survival should a
catastrophic event occur but they also
held a Sinister secret many of the
vaults performed cruel experiments one
of my favorites is the story of Vault 11
where every year the inhabitants had to
select one person to sacrifice or else
they'd all be killed the experiment
continued for years until only five
original inhabitants remained now it
looks like some of the Dwellers of Vault
33 have weapons and this poor girl even
has a fork in her eye but what I'm super
curious about is this woman in a dress
watching this attack unfold she doesn't
seem panicked at all and isn't wearing a
vault uniform what's her deal Lucy
arrives at this small town cobbled
together by wck P AG an homage to
Fallout 3's town of Megaton obviously it
can't be the real Megaton since that's
all the way in DC this place even has
the same airplane nose and Supply sign
composed of different letters but check
out what's in the far distance looks
like a ruined Los Angeles now here's our
first look at Walter goggin known simply
as the ghoul ghouls are humans who are
essentially mutants affected by
radiation they are sterile beings who
can live for hundreds of years so when
we see Walter gogin here in human form
with a young girl you just know he's
going to have a tragic backstory dating
back to the Great War of 2077 they're
wearing matching outfits coincidentally
in the vault colors of yellow and blue
so my guess is that this is his daughter
and she dies in the attack making him
this wandering Bandit character with
nothing to live for another gorgeous
shot of Lucy traversing the land coming
across this home where Diaper Man greets
her we get our first little bit of
action here as the ghoul takes down a
bunch of gun Gunslingers in town I'm not
exactly sure when this happens or if and
how it relates to Lucy's presence here
Lucy has a chat with this Pleasant
oneeyed vault tech his physical
deformity most likely a result of
radiation leads me to believe this isn't
Vault 33 but some sort of vault tech
facility out in the world here's a
please remain calm turret just going
wild at a man in a white lap coat
escaping with the dog he's also holding
a bag of something perhaps running away
with secret Tech or information taking
the dog is also a choice voice
indicating that it may be more than just
a friendly companion he or she may be
linked to something much bigger here's
our first glimpse of Mr handy a series
of hovering robots who would eventually
be used as domestic servants and it
looks like Mr handy is giving Lucy a
helping hand who is injured absolutely
love this shot of overseer Hank Lucy's
father and leader of Vault 33 and it has
me asking a lot of questions is this
inside Vault 33 before Lucy leaves or
does he eventually make it out and this
is sometime later maximus in the middle
of an attack perhaps on a Raider camp we
can see power armor and a Verte bird in
the background and what would a Fallout
trailer be without a mutated grizzly
bear just absolutely tearing apart this
Soldier now who could this be Lucy
possibly in their left hand is a white
case and right either a mask or black
bag but I definitely get the sense they
are running away from something rather
than toward now look at this beautiful
aquatic creature if you look on the
bottom right it looks to have someone in
its grasp now is it just me or do some
of these things look like fingers a
glorious shot of this absolutely massive
Brotherhood Airship similar to the
pridwin found in Fallout 4 this appears
to be some sort of Brotherhood military
base our final shot is of Los Angeles
getting absolutely decimated by nukes
but there are some cool little details
here on the far right you can see Walter
goggin's human character and that little
girl on that horse could they be making
their way to a nearby by vault in the
mountains we do see an ad for a vault on
this billboard down here what if this
girl is his daughter and she got into a
vault but not him it could mean that his
descendants are still alive in the world
and potentially even in the same vault
as Lucy I don't know about you guys but
I'm very optimistic about this show so I
hope you'll join me on April 12th when
the first episode drops but now I turn
it over to you what did you think of the
first trailer I want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching please be sure
to like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at@ thinkstory YT until next
time remember Daddy loves you very
much